tous
je pense
madame monsieur bonsoir alger à feu et à
sang
l'état de siège est proclamé l'armée
essaie de rétablir l'ordre
le chili a dit non au général pinochet
qui reste légalement pour pouvoir le
gouvernement a démissionné
nîmes et ses 70 communes déclarées en
état de catastrophe naturelle
opération solidarité ce soir sur antenne
2 l'état de siège à alger pour la
première fois en 26 ans d'indépendance
le régime algérien fait donner l'armée
les violentes manifestations qui avaient
commencé hier en tournée aujourd'hui à
l'émeute
il y a des blessés des arrestations en
grand nombre tout de suite le point de
la situation avec martine
laroche-joubert
pour le moment nous n'avons reçu que ces
images de la télévision algérienne les
rues de la capitale dévastée après les
affrontements d'hier où des jeunes de 12
à bâtons ont renversé les voitures brisé
des vitrines incendié des bâtiments
publics
symbole de l'opulence de l'état ou du
parti aux cris de jeunes levé vous mais
aujourd'hui la situation s'est
considérablement aggravée en fin de
matinée barricades enflammées en travers
de la chaussée au centre d'alger et dans
ses banlieues incendie multiples dont
celui du ministère de l'éducation et de
la formation
des centaines de jeunes dans la cité de
bach jara à l'est d'alger munis de
pierres face à des militaires en
treillis
la réaction des autorités ne s'est plus
fait attendre des blindés se sont postés
devant les bâtiments officiels et aux
points stratégiques le port le parlement
la télévision des coups de feu ont
claqué au centre d'alger dans les
petites rues près du siège du parti
il y aurait des blessés par balles enfin
l'état de siège a été décrété en début
d'après midi pour la première fois
depuis l'indépendance en 1962
toutes les autorités civiles
administratives et de sécurité sont
placés sous commandement militaire
régulièrement à la télévision
le commandement militaire la population
qui veut rétablir l ordre avec vigueur
et par tous les moyens qu'impose la
situation dans le calme des passagers
viennent de débarquer d'alger par avion
ils nous décrivent ce qu'ils ont vu la
situation est assez mauvaise fin ce
matin en partant l'aérodrome on a encore
plus des supermarchés qui brûlait et
puis des camions écrasé par tous sur
autoroute
vous avez vu des émeutes oui puisque
nous mêmes nous avons été pris plus ou
moins dans une émeute
facet cet angoissant voilà donc pour la
situation à alger en province la
situation est plus calme sauf en kabylie
où des mouvements de protestation ont
été signalés alors quelles sont les
explications fournies d'abord par le
régime lui même pierre serra les a
demandé tout à l'heure à l'ambassadeur
d'algérie en france
mais voyez vous je ne pense pas qu'il
faille dramatiser les choses comme vous
le faites à notre sens c'était situation
sérieuse mais je pense à mon avis
l'algérie est en train de vivre une
crise de jeunesse une crise de
croissance
à mon sens les causes sont multiples en
tout cas il y en a deux essentiels
l'une d'ordre démographique la
population algérienne qu'on savait croît
très rapidement et aujourd'hui 75% de la
population a moins de 25 ans la deuxième
cause elle est d'ordre économique
il est clair que l'algérie avec la crise
pétrolière avec la chute des prix du
pétrole et vous savez que
malheureusement notre économie est
largement tributaire des hydrocarbures
connaît une crise assez sérieuse que
connaissent d'ailleurs beaucoup de pays
en voie de développement créatif c'est
une situation très difficile non
c'est constitutionnellement dans notre
constitution c'est l'étape d'exception
qui est des situations très difficiles
et assiègent est un premier stade je ne
minimise pas les choses je voulais dit
d'emblée le remède ce que nous pensons
que il convient tout d'abord de rétablir
lot
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que le
désordre et l'anarchie règne dans notre
pays mais ceci étant il est
indispensable non moins indispensable de
prendre des mesures sur le plan
économique et social qui sont
nécessaires pour répondre aux
aspirations de notre peuple la voix de
l'opposition maintenant deux algeria en
exil livre d'accord une pertuis leur
analyse de ces événements
ahmed benbella par téléphone de suisse
et attaques mais de l'un des plus
anciens opposants au régime
plus les focales idée réellement ce pays
dit en france depuis déjà deux mains et
l'orage bol général
le félin colère et le désespoir qui a
poussé toute nouvelle population
le peuple algérien au départ à 206 nos
valeurs nos enfants là bas ils ont voté
comme vous pas la possibilité de voter
c'est pas 355% que nous aurions fait 4 à
4 ans aujourd'hui si j'avais à faire un
appel ce serait au pouvoir
osons du coup moi de leur dire ne
touchez pas à la chair de notre chair
c'est cette génération là elle un
dynamisme extraordinaire
vous avez pour deux mois n'en est pas
seulement que des droits sur cette
société pour deux mois de permettre à ce
dynamisme de s'exprimer d'une manière
positive dans le dieu gloire dans le
développement du pays et cela ne peut se
faire que par leur établissement une vie
politique normale le rétablissement des
libertés indiqué cette jeunesse trouve
des canaux d'expression
il faut qu'il se sente responsable qui
participent et c'est de cette manière
quelques devenir majeur c'est elle qui
doit prendre les rênes du pouvoir
j'ai divisé il ya une année à propos des
droits de l'homme que l'algérie devrait
être le phare des droits de l'homme
je crois que c'est l'heure de vérité
maintenant toute la journée la
télévision et la radio officielle ont
lancé en algérie des appels au calme
voici comment il ya quelques minutes à
peine le journal télévisé local informer
les habitants
hervé brusini
irresponsables vandalisme affirme le
commentateur de la radio télévision
algérienne ces images en tout cas
reflète l'ampleur de la violence qui
s'est emparée d'alger ici il y avait un
grand magasin cela se passe dans un
quartier populaire d'alger insiste le
commentaire ou alors mal est-il ami qui
a commis de tels actes journalistes
algériens parlent de fauteurs de
troubles
des jeunes apparemment manipuler dit-il
par l'étrange taxés à hauteur de 1000
monte leucate et la momie pour le voir
plusieurs incendies ont été allumés à
l'intérieur de la capitale
voici l'intérieur d'alger
le port apparemment plus tranquille là
aussi un incendie probablement des pneus
barak a promis à marc thomas à présent
nous sommes au centre ville là encore
l'image d'affrontements ces images sont
diffusées en ce moment même par la
télévision algérienne notamment john a
new show will be nice
les émeutiers on le devine d'en haut ont
incendié des bâtiments publics symbole
du régime et aussi des centres
commerciaux
symbole d'une société de consommation
dont ils sont exclus
la situation économique est
catastrophique l'alimentation hors de
prix et les deux tiers des algériens ont
moins de 25 ans jacques merlino depuis
deux semaines les signes d'une explosion
possible se multipliaient les grèves se
développait dans plusieurs usines et
l'on rapportait qu'ici ou là des camions
transportant de la nourriture avaient
été attaqués par une population
exaspérée
c'est que dans ce pays plus rien ne va
la crise de logement est terrible par
exemple ici à bab el oued
il faut s'en passer à 8 dans deux pièces
quant au prix et galope un rythme annuel
de 200 % d'inflation
le kilo de viande vote aujourd'hui 200
francs et le kilo d'orange près de 20
francs pour des salaires qui dépasse
difficilement 1000 francs par mois très
difficiles de ce volet qui gagnent trop
et 1000 1500 on se débrouille en nous
développant un autre endroit que eudora
de son nom gloire crise économique
accentués encore par la chute des prix
du pétrole alors que les hydrocarbures
représentent 90% des recettes en devises
mais la cause majeure de cette crise est
bien sûr l'explosion démographique ce
pays comptait 9 millions d'habitants
en 1962 il en compte aujourd'hui 22
millions et 60 % de cette population a
moins de 20 ans des jeunes désoeuvrés
ayant peu d'espoir de trouver un emploi
une vie culturelle inexistante une
bureaucratie pesant tout cela se
conjugue aujourd'hui explique ces
émeutes
sans compter que depuis quelques années
le gouvernement algérien s'est lancé
dans une série de réformes et que si
celle-ci enrichissent certains elle
provoque une opposition radicale dans de
nombreux milieux 54 68 % pour le non 43
0 4% pour le oui ce sont les résultats à
peu près définitif du plébiscite que le
général pinochet avait organisé hier au
chili pour demander à ses compatriotes
de lui accorder huit années de plus au
pouvoir depuis l'annoncé des résultats
ce matin la joie gagne la rue les
manifestants tentent parfois de
fraterniser avec les forces de l'ordre
mais vous le voyez la police vient de
disperser à coups de gaz lacrymogènes et
de canon a eu ce qu'ils voulaient d'un
peu trop près manifesté leur hostilité
au général président
les présidentielles selon la loi le
général pinochet est au pouvoir pour un
an encore sur place à santiago
bernard benyamin apparemment rien n'a
changé et pourtant tout est déjà
différent les signes de cette
transformation ne sont pas encore
facilement repérables mais il est vrai
que ce matin
sentiez-vous était un peu groggy par
l'ivresse de la victoire de la nuit
précédente
rien n'a changé mais les vendeurs de rue
ont déjà fait disparaître toutes les
publicités relatives au oui la chanson
du nom fait actuellement un tabac dans
la capitale chilienne
pour le moment ça se vend très bien
après on verra en fonction de ce qui va
se passer
rien n'a changé le général pinochet
toujours mettre au palais de la moneda
mais depuis cette nuit il n'y a plus de
gouvernement le cabinet lui a présenté
sa démission collective
rien n'a changé la vie du centre ville
est toujours rythmé par les protestants
les manifestations mais depuis hier soir
on ne crie plus et vaka m
il va tomber mais y'a caillou il est
déjà tombé
rien n'a changé non plus à radio
coopérative la radio d'opposition la
plus populaire au chili mais pourtant là
encore il y a des choses qui ne trompait
pas exemple les journalistes avaient
parié sur le résultat des élections mais
ce qui n'était qu'un jeu et qu'un rêve
s'est transformé hier soir en réalité et
le vainqueur n'a même pas pensé à venir
chercher sa mise
quant au rédacteur en chef de cette
radio il se garde bien de tout
triomphalisme
et pourtant il vit sans doute l'un des
plus beaux jours de sa vie
rien n'a changé
mais tous déjà rien n'a changé et
pourtant tout est différent
il est vrai qu'on ne sort pas oui ça a
été le reportage de bernabé la ville a
été interrompue un peu brutalement mais
je crois que nous en avons vu
l'essentiel le gouvernement donc à
présenter sa démission le général
pinochet devrait bientôt annoncer la
composition d'un nouveau gouvernement
les rapports de force entre l'opposition
victorieuse et le régime sont encore
confus l'opposition va-t-elle obtenir
une modification de la constitution pour
qu'un successeur soit désigné au plus
vite
et est ce qu'elle est en mesure
elle-même de maintenir son unité
l'analyse sur place de bernard benyamin
en fait il ya deux questions que l'on se
pose après ce vote que l'on peut
qualifier d'historique la première que
vont faire les militaires ils peuvent
fort bien accepter le résultat sorti des
urnes
jouer à fond la légalité c'est en gros
la position de la marine et de
l'aviation
mais ils peuvent aussi c'est le cas de
l'armée de terre succomber à la
tentation du coup d'état c'est une
hypothèse tout à fait réaliste deuxième
question vous le savez la constitution
prévoit la tenue d'élections
présidentielles d'ici un an
or ce qui ressort de tous les contacts
que nous avons eus ici c'est que le
général pinochet aura énormément de mal
à se maintenir au pouvoir jusqu'à la fin
de l'année prochaine certains secteurs
de l'armée
serait d'ores et déjà prêt à entamer des
négociations avec les partis politiques
afin de hâter la transition
reste que c'est la première fois qu'un
régime militaire est lui-même victime
d'un processus qui l'a déclenchée quinze
ans après le coup d'état de septembre
ce n'est pas la moindre des surprises à
washington la maison blanche se déclare
très satisfaite du bon déroulement du
plébiscite et à paris selon le porte
parole de l'elysée le président
mitterrand a exprimé sa joie profonde
à l'annoncé des résultats une
information de toute dernière minute en
provenance d'alger le couvre-feu vient
d'être décrétée sur la région d'alger
les habitants sont donc sommés de
regagner immédiatement leur domicile je
vous le répète donc état d'urgence mais
aussi couvre feu depuis ce soir à alger
un milliard de francs c'est le montant
débloqué par le gouvernement pour
satisfaire les infirmières leur nouveau
mouvement de grève a été massivement
suivie aujourd'hui à paris - en province
des négociations sont en cours entre la
coordination des infirmières les
syndicats et le ministre de la santé
françoise joly en grève et dans la rue à
paris elle était aujourd'hui plus de 25
mille bus blanche à manifester leurs
revendications toujours la même une
augmentation de 2000 francs par mois
mais un conflit qui a surtout pour toile
de fond un débordement des syndicats
ceux ci se déclare seul habilité à
négocier avec le ministère de la santé
les infirmières en grève elle revendique
ce droit pour ce qu'elle appelle la
coordination un mouvement spontané qui
est à l'origine
que les mécanos représente que 5 % de la
profession dans mon dos me gêne nous
écouter nous sommes incontournables
l'avant de l'avion
le ministère de la santé à lui donner
raison aux syndicats ce sont eux et eux
seuls qui se sont assis ce soir à 18
heures autour de la table des
négociations
oui nous refusons cette participation de
la coordination pour trois raisons la
première c'est que pour négocier il faut
être élu et nous avons été élus le 3 au
mois de mars dernier pour représenter
par son hospitalier la deuxième raison
c'est qu'un accord ça se gère il faut
être présent dans l'ensemble des
établissements pour le faire appliquer
est la troisième raison c'est que la
coordination est aujourd'hui un
phénomène parisien en ce moment même ici
au ministère de la santé les
négociations se poursuivent entre le
ministre claude evin et les syndicats
d'ores et déjà le ministère a proposé
une augmentation de 300 francs pour les
infirmières en début de carrière et 2100
francs pour celle en fin de carrière
soit après 34 ans de service des
propositions assorti de mesures de
formation tout cela est chiffré à un
milliard de francs et des propositions
qui reste très en dessous de ce que
réclament les syndicats et la
coordination des infirmières une
coordination toujours exclu pour
l'instant de ces négociations
le procès des assassins présumés de
georges besse n'aura pas lieu demain
comme prévu les dirigeants ans d'action
directe comparaîtront devant la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris lundi
prochain au plus tôt en effet le
mouvement de protestation des gardiens
de prison qui touche maintenant plus de
la moitié des établissements empêche la
justice de suivre son cours gilbert
bonnemaison le député-maire socialiste
chargé du problème par le garde des
sceaux a visité aujourd'hui les prisons
de lyon et marseille avant de reprendre
ce soir les négociations avec les
syndicats
dominique et puis je visitais mais
client en demande cet avocat
comment mes clients
non et une fois de plus les piquets de
grève répondre pour m ripert l'un des
avocats d'action directe
l'urgence est toute particulière puisque
c'était demain en principe que devait
s'ouvrir le procès en assises des
auteurs présumés de la science à de
l'assassinât de georges besse
dans ces conditions de fait la défense
envisage pas la tenue du procès mes
clients sont extrêmes qui ne soit pas je
pense que ça va me changer en plus rien
au problème d'être au plus tard pour que
ce procès puisse devenir par le respect
mais drogba défense ultime tentative
rencontré le directeur de fleury mérogis
là encore même barrage même
détermination
après neuf jours de conflit
l'institution judiciaire frise la parade
les procès sont renvoyés à des dates
ultérieures par dizaines près de 100
établissements sont touchés par le
mouvement de protestation des
surveillants
dès hier dès sa nomination en tant que
médiateur gilbert bonnemaison s'est mise
au travail visite éclair aux baumettes à
marseille puis à lyon
enfin réunions souvent même à la
chancellerie avec l'intersyndicale des
gardiens de prison gilbert bonnemaison
s'est refusé à tout commentaire pour
l'instant
mais chacun reconnaît que la situation
devient critique situation explosive
ajoutent à leur tour les syndicats de
police 150 commissariat héberge près de
500 détenus dans des conditions
d'hygiène précaires pour la fédération
autonome des syndicats de police la
solution au conflit
ces deux rattachés les personnels de
l'administration pénitentiaire au
ministère de l'intérieur à nouveau la
passe dans l' enquête sur le meurtre de
la petite delphine les quatre
responsables du camp scout qui avait été
gardé à vue pendant 48 heures ont été
remis en liberté à l'aube aucune charge
n'a été retenue contre grève de 240
salariés dans un atelier de l'usiné
renault du mans c'est assez pour obliger
la direction à arrêter depuis hier soir
la production des camionnettes express à
boulogne billancourt et ce soir à
sandouville
l'essentiel est de participer c'est en
filigrane un slogan presque un pic que
vous allez entendre tout au long de la
campagne pour le référendum sur la
nouvelle calédonie sans l'imagination
des publicitaires il n'y a pas de vraie
campagne voici donc en primeur le clip
que jacques séguéla a conçu pour le
compte du gouvernement
nouvelle calédonie ils ont fait le geste
de fraternité
à notre tour de faire un geste de
fraternité en votant le 6 novembre
référendum pour l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie
6 novembre le geste de fraternité
le prochain référendum a alimenté
aujourd'hui encore l'essentiel des
conversations dans la classe politique
le président du fn jean marie tjibaou a
été reçu à sa demande ce matin pendant
plus d'une heure par jacques chirac
un entretien cordial dit-on bien que le
président du rpr se soit refusé à toute
déclaration
le mouvement vous le savez fera
connaître sa position officielle sur le
référendum
à la fin de la semaine prochaine jean
marie tjibaou avait rencontré auparavant
françois léotard qui s'est par ailleurs
entretenu avec pierre méhaignerie leurs
positions sont assez voisines pour
recommander une réponse positive au
référendum
quant à jean marie le pen il a déclaré
aujourd'hui à milan lors d'un colloque
de l'euro droite qu'il souhaitait que
les partisans du non bénéficient des
mêmes droits que les partisans du non au
chili de réaction encore à l'allocution
hier des premiers ministres sur le
référendum celle du parti socialiste et
du parti communiste que l'on n'avait pas
encore entendu
alors à part après l'annnonce du texte
de loi et de la question par le premier
ministre qui nous pose pas qu'il nous
pose pas de problème
le comité central va se réunir mercredi
et va appeler certainement les
françaises et français a répondu oui au
référendum du 6 novembre
il faut que la majorité les français
viennent voter qu'ils votent oui pour
l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie
souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois la
nouvelle calédonie est au bord du
gouffre au bord de la guerre civile la
paix a été restauré les deux communautés
ont choisi leur avenir ensemble et je
crois que le peuple français ne peut
qu'approuver cette démarche il faut
voter pour ce référendum
c'est un engagement solennel et il n'y a
pas de meilleure expression de la
souveraineté nationale que justement le
référendum l'engagement de tous les
français
la commission interministérielle réuni à
cet effet a déclaré officiellement tout
à l'heure la ville de nîmes et les 70
communes de son arrondissement en état
de catastrophe naturelle
elles vont donc bénéficier de crédits
d'exception toutes les énergies de la
ville sont mobilisent
et sous l'impulsion de son maire pour
retrouver le cours normal de la vie
collective
les opérations de déblaiement continuer
les dons de toutes natures afflux
régnante quatre hangars réquisitionnés
dans des entrepôts de la périphérie de
nîmes
c'est ici qu'est collecter tout ce qui
peut venir en aide aux sinistrés
particuliers entreprises municipalités
déchargement arrivent sans cesse de
partout et souvent dus au delà des
limites du département du gard en ville
dans l'un des douze centres de
répartition 500 lycéens qui n'ont
toujours pas repris les cours ont offert
leurs services pour sillonner les
quartiers meurtri mission rassurer
nettoyer logement recensé les besoins ou
c'est plus dur voire traumatisant seller
ce qu'ils arrivent chez des personnes
âgées par exemple qui refuse dans un
premier temps c'est peut-être parce
qu'elles sont complètement repliée sur
elle-même traumatisée et certains nous
ont dit avoir vu des personnes âgées de
l'eau jusqu'aux genoux ne pas vouloir
parler et refuser même d'ouvrir leurs
portes ouvertes trek
à leur retour les équipes passent leurs
commandes qui seront livrés au plus vite
parfois des sinistrés viennent
directement au centre chercher du
secours
certains hébété n'ont qu'une phrase
geffard la plupart viennent demander
quelques vêtements une table un lit une
couverture une lampe à pétrole bref tout
ce dont on a besoin
quand on a tout perdu et pour beaucoup
venir ici ou accueillir les équipes de
bénévoles s'est aussi discuté sourire
reprendre espoir
ces mêmes que la moyenne pour me faire
parvenir à monter
il fallait
certains
sur place à la mairie de nîmes ce soir
claude sérillon lourde à partir de 22h
vous allez donc animé cette édition
spéciale qui a mobilisé les énergies de
toute la rédaction votre but
alors notre but à partir de 22 heures je
donne tout de suite le rendez vous c'est
de faire d'abord de l'information de
faire un petit peu le point sur l'état
des lieux vous l'avez vu avec ce
reportage de rémy roche l'état des
secours l'état de la solidarité c'était
ma foi très impressionnant non seulement
de faire l'information mais aussi poser
quelques questions sur un propos de la
météo à propos des assurances à propos
de l'organisation peut être futur de la
ville de nîmes notamment dans le côté
industriels et commerçants nous aurons
ici dans ce grand hall de la mairie de
nîmes beaucoup de témoins des gens qui
sont quelquefois totalement sinistré et
puis des industrielles beaucoup de gens
qui viendront aussi directement via les
voies hertziennes parler de solidarité
de barcelone de bordeaux de nancy de
beaucoup d'autres villes elle vient d'en
dire ce qu'elles peuvent apporter à la
ville de nîmes
j'aurais simplement aussi avec à partir
de 22h cette émission spéciale sera
aussi une émission de solidarité et pour
commencer cette émission nous vous
proposerons un document qui a été tourné
par un nîmois un amateur nîmois qui a
vécu cette catastrophe et vous verrez
ces images sont très impressionnantes
elles font bien comprendre l'étendue des
dégâts
des gars que nous avons constaté depuis
deux jours ici avec toute une partie de
la rédaction d'antenne 2 elle a rendez
vous à 22 heures claude merci une autre
opération vous avez vu suivre tout au
long de la journée sur antenne 2 la
journée du coeur en association avec la
fédération française de cardiologie
tous les ans vous le savez quelques
cinquante mille personnes meurent en
france d' attaque cardiaque
le but de cette opération réduire les
délais d intervention et sauver des vies
alain à vous a recueilli les témoignages
de poids ceux de deux hommes que vous
connaissez bien et qui ont survécu à des
accidents cardiaques
les moniteurs une conférence je me suis
couché
impossible de m'endormir et puis la
fameuse douleur ça fait bien on a décrit
toujours là la poitrine enrôler épaules
et très bon réflexe de ma femme que je
réveille car elle dormait appelé le
médecin ils arrivent aussitôt il
constate une anomalie appelle le samu
qui elle un quart d'heure après
et en quart d'heure plus tard loi sur
l'hôpital et je dois dire curieusement
que grâce à cette rapidité
je n'ai pas eu d'envoi je n'ai pas eu
peur et j'ai eu raison
on m'a fait un double pontage puisque
les coronaires était en très mauvais
état et ça réussit tout va bien
maintenant deux ans après on peut
rassurer tout le monde
bah oui je suis ministre rentrant chez
moi après avoir enregistré une émission
à la télévision j'ai été pris d'une
douleur brutale ici à la poitrine
je me suis douté que j'avais un
infarctus j'ai immédiatement appelé un
docteur
ce docteur m'a dirigé vers un centre
spécialisé à lariboisière
moins de deux heures après que commencer
cette douleur j'étais déjà à
lariboisière
est ce que vous avez eu peur j'ai eu
peur j'ai peur bien sûr quand on a je me
suis douté que c'était un infarctus mais
j'ai des doutes vite rassuré quand je me
suis trouvé dans ce service spécialiste
aujourd'hui treize ans après treize ans
après et bien je suis en très bonne
santé
je n'ai aucune séquelle je travaille
normalement
par conséquent si j'ai une
recommandation à faire la rapidité avant
de nous quitter je vous propose de
retourner brièvement alger avec les
toutes dernières images qui viennent de
nous parvenir et qui font bien
comprendre l'ampleur des émeutes qui le
plus vieil air donc ont lieu dans la
capitale algérienne
je vous le rappelle le couvre-feu est
donc décrété depuis ce soir les
habitants sont sommés de rentrer chez
eux au plus vite
l'armée a pris le contrôle de
l'administration et de tous les services
publics le commandement militaire par le
biais de la télévision et de la radio le
continue de lancer des appels au calme à
la population je vous le rappelle ce
sont essentiellement des ministères et
aussi des supermarchés des magasins qui
ont été incendiés très vite encore les
résultats du tiercé qui s'est courue
aujourd'hui à saint cloud le doubs
le 1 et le 4 les rapports pour 5 francs
dans l'ordre 1112 francs 50 et dans un
ordre différent
222 francs 50 voilà donc à 22 heures je
vous le rappelle vous avez rendez vous
avec claude sérillon à nîmes pour une
édition spéciale vers 23h30 philippe
lefait vous donnera les dernières
informations de la journée demain 6h45
télématin invité des 4 vérités le
chanoine laine qui coordonne la
prochaine visite du pape jean paul ii
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal très
bonne soirée à demain 20 heures
compagnie